nuditionnons ce matin monsieur Éric
Dupont Moretti garde des saau ministre
de la Justice monsieur le ministre c'est
la première fois depuis le
renouvellement sénatorial que nous vous
accueillons au sein de la délégation aux
droits des femmes du Sénat mais nous
nous connaissons bien puisque vous êtes
un interlocuteur naturel de la
délégation sur les sujets qui sont au
cœur de ses compétences la lutte contre
les violences conjugales et contre les
violences sexuelles et
sexistes nous vous avions auditionné l
du précédent trienna le 7 juillet
2021 et nous avons personnellement
beaucoup échangé dans le cadre de
l'élaboration du plan rouge juif sur
l'amélioration du traitement judiciaire
des violences intrafamiliales que j'ai
corédigé avec notre collègue député
Émilie
Chandeleur encore aujourd'hui vous
m'associez régulièrement au suivi de la
mise en œuvre des mesures proposées et
je vous en suis
reconnaissante concernant la lutte
contre les violences intrafamiliales
beaucoup de dispositifs existent déjà il
faut désormais les déployer pleinement
et en faire bénéficier le maximum de
victimes la question de la formation des
forces de l'ordre et des magistrats au
traitement des violences est cependant
toujours au cœur de nos préoccupations
j'y ajouterai même d'ailleurs la
violence la la violence excusez-moi la
formation de tous les acteurs y compris
de du secteur social je pense également
que l'absence de coordination
interministérielle dans le suivi de
l'application des mesures de lutte
contre les violences peut être
préjudiciable
euh vous le savez s'agissant des moyens
consacrés à cette politique vous savez
également que je plaide pour la création
d'un fond dédié à la lutte contre les
vifs afin de ne plus entendre de la CAF
je n'ai pas de ligne pour financer ça ou
du ministère de la Justice je ne
financerait pas ça tout seul trouver un
autre partenaire et en gros
effectivement vous connaissez
mon ce que je souhaite c'est une
politique pilotée avec un fond
dédié au-delà des vifs il y a d'autres
sujets que je souhaite aborder avec vous
ce matin dans un premier temps la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles et
sexiste notamment le traitement
judiciaire des plaintes pour violence
sexuelle alors que les plaintes pour
viol donnent rarement lieu à des
investigations poussées le suivi par les
procureurs qui en ont la charge qui ont
en charge la direction des enquêtes
pourrait être renforcé encore très
récemment lors de la Journée nationale
de lutte contre le sexisme le 25 janvier
une advocate nous a indiqué que la
première question posé par un policier à
une de ses
clientes venue déposer plainte pour viol
a été avez-vous pris du plaisir pendant
l'acte je vous le recommande non mais
elle était très bonne celle-ci
aujourd'hui on le sait d'après des
chiffres publiés par le HCE en octobre
2022 moins de 10 % des victimes de
violence sexuelle déposent plainte 80 %
des plaintes pour viol sont classés sans
suite 1 % de ces plaintes aboutissent à
une condamnation
judiciaire dès lors comment mieux
qualifier poursivre et condamner ces
violences sexuelles pourriez-vous nous
dresser un premier bilan du traitement
des affaires de viol par les cours
criminales départementales c'est un
débat que nous avons eu aussi leur mise
en place a-t-elle permis de mettre fin à
la correctionnalisation des viols un
débat est en cours sur la définition
pénale du viol nos collègues de la
délégation au droits des femmes de
l'Assemblée ont d'ailleurs entamé une
mission sur le sujet et une modification
de la définition européenne du viol
fondée sur le consentement étant
discussion au Parlement européen quelle
est votre position sur ce débat je vois
que je pose la question mais je sais que
ça c une question qui intéressait l'une
de nos collègues
également autre sujet que je souhaite
aborder ici le projet de loi
constitutionnel relative à la liberté de
recourir à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse il a été adopté par nos
collègues députés par un vote solennel
mardi 30 janvier sera examiné au Sénat
d'abord en commission des lois le 14
février puis en séance le 28
février j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire publiquement et nos récents travaux
sur l'état du droit et de l'accès à
l'IVG dans le monde en novembre dernier
nous le laisse penser même en France la
liberté pour les femmes de recourir à
l'IVG n'est pas imuable et pourrait un
jour être menacé je suis donc à titre
personnel favorable à la
constitutionnalisation de cette liberté
il me semble également que les droits
sociaux et humains les plus fondamentaux
comme celui pour une femme de disposer
de son corps ont vocation à être inscrit
dans la
Constitution monsieur le ministre
peut-être pourriez-vous nous donner
quelques éléments de calendrier
s'agissant de la convocation du
Parlement en congrès qui a un petit peu
fait tousser le Sénat si ce texte
constitutionnel était adopté dans les
mêmes termes par les deux assemblées et
nous rappeler l'intérêt de la
formulation
retenue enfin je souhaite de vous
interroger sur un point plus technique
qui concerne les travaux en cours de la
délégation aux droits des femmes sur les
familles
monoparentales nous avons notamment été
sensibilisé aux inégalités de procédure
dans le traitement judiciaire des
séparations familiales qui peuvent
déboucher sur des modalités disparates
de calcul de pensions alimentaires or le
montant moyen d'une pension alimentaire
aujourd'hui qui est de 170 € par mois
est loin de couvrir la moitié du coût de
l'éducation d'un enfant qui est de
l'ordre de 750 € par mois donc divisé
par 2 c'est 375 si je ne m'abuse et donc
170 effectivement on est loin du compte
si la mise en place de l'ARIPA agence de
recouvrement et de l'intermédiation des
pensions alimentaires a constitué un
réel progrès en matière de versement
effectif de la pension une
sensibilisation des juges familiaux au
risque de précarisation des mères qui
élèvent seul leurs enfants nous semble
indispensable puisque je le rappelle 41
% des enfants vivant dans une famille
monopar ent sont sous le seuil de
pauvreté contre 16 % des enfants vivant
dans une famille dont les parents sont
en couple monsieur le ministre je vous
laisse sans tarder la parole et je
proposerai après votre propos
introductif à mes collègues
d'intervenir bien merci madame la
Présidente mesames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs à
venir non je d'abord vous dire que c'est
un grand grand plaisir pour moi d'être
parmi vous ce matin et de vous euh
retrouver en cette année
nouvelle petite parenthèse l'officier de
police judiciaire qui dit à
une qui demande à une victime si elle a
éprouvé du
plaisir pardon ce n'est pas mon
périmètre mais je me demande franchement
ce qui fait dans la police et quand
j'entends ce que vous me dites les
oreilles m' tombent et et je pense
que si les choses se précisaient et
qu'elles étaient transmises à Gérald
hermanin je pense qu'il n'hésiterait pas
une seule seconde à tirer les
conséquences qui méritent d'être tiré
d'un tel
comportement insupportable d'entendre
des choses pareilles
aujourd'hui ce qui signifie au fond et
c'est une transition comme disent les
commentateur
radiophonique que le combat n'est pas
terminé qui reste encore beaucoup de
boulot à faire et que le chemin euh est
encore long donc je suis ravi de de de
reprendre avec vous ce ce dialogue il
est
indispensable naturellement je connais
votre engagement
total madame la
Présidente euh mesdames les sénatrices
et on va euh je vais essayer de répondre
le plus complètement possible aux
questions
que légitimement euh vous me posez
bon votre délégation est pour moi
une interlocutrice si j'ose dire
absolument et et une partenaire
absolument
privilégiée et je vais en venir tout de
suite au sujet qui nous mobilise et qui
nous
préoccupe la protection des droits des
femmes passe
évidemment matière de justice par la
lutte contre les violences faites à la
rcontre alors les bilans sont sont
encourageants mais les mots doivent être
mesurés personne ne peut faire de de de
culturisme judiciaire évidemment
et une violence un
féminicide c'est toujours une violence
et un féminicide de trop là aussi c'est
une évidence les travaux parlementaires
récents permettent de soulligner comm
matière de violence
intrafamiliale on est engagé de manière
euh irréversible
pour faire reculer ce ce fléo
indigne et je vais me concentrer si vous
le voulez bien sur les chantiers
résolument
engagés mon CAP est clair ma
détermination est totale il faut
détecter
plutôt pourquoi je le dis parce que la
justice évidemment ne peut pas
intervenir si elle n'est pas saisie si
elle n'est pas alertée si son attention
n'a pas été
attirée il faut protéger les victimes
tout au long de la procédure tout en
développant simultanément bien sûr la
prise en
charge renforcer des
auteurs cette lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales repose désormais sur des
réponses et sur des réformes qui sont
profondes et qui sont effectives je vous
annoncer d'abord que en
2023 le nombre de drame
évités grâce au bracelet
antiraapprochement a été multiplié par 3
passant de
3634 en 2022 à près de
100500 interventions des forces de
l'ordre que je veux évidemment remercier
c'est autant de femmes sauvés
d'enfants d'enfants
sauvés toujours sur
ces pardonnez-moi sur ces outils de de
protection téléphone grave danger ont
aussi permis d'éviter 2500 drames en
2022 les ordonnances de protection ont
également permis de sauver des vies
elles étaient prononcées bon vous le
savez en 42 jours c'est désormais 6
jours et ce sera dans quelques jours pas
dire dans quelques heures 24 he grâce à
votre proposition madame la Présidente
de en cas d'urgence urgence détectée par
le procureur de la République alors par
ailleurs une avancée majeure vient
d'être votée à l'Assemblée nationale
grâce au groupe modem s'agit de rétablir
une justice patrimoniale
euh ce texte sera prochainement soumis
au Sénat l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes et la lutte contre les
violences conjugales
euh se doivent être menés sur tous les
fronts ce texte permet de
d'éviter que l'auteur d'un homicide à
l'encontre de son
conjoint puisse bénéficier du régime
matrimonial on avait déjà réglé la
question de l'héritage et voyez parfois
les choses que l'on a sous les yeux et
qui sont
évidentes au fond il il a fallu que l'un
de vos collègues dise mais
euh le bénéfice du régime matrimonial
personne ne se dit que il est impossible
qu'il vienne bénéficier à l'auteur d'un
meurtre et ce texte évidemment a emporté
l'adhésion du garde des saut aussi parce
que c'était tellement logique et
tellement évident que personne ne
l'avait vu et donc ce texte a été porté
par moi avec enthousiasme et il a fait
l'objet d'un consensus très très large
et je pense que on retrouvera le même
consensus devant votre
assemblé tous les champs de
l'intervention judiciaire doivent être
exploités absolument tous et c'est cette
approche
globale autour d'une même situation
familiale qui est
consacrée dans les textes de novembre
2023 qui pent évidemment création
despôes vif dans toutes les juridiction
tous les tribunaux devant toutes les
cours
d'appel texte est effectif depuis la
mise en place de ces pôes
spécialisés est désormais une réalité
depuis le 1er
janvier cette réforme a été
particulièrement bien accueilli
euh par les
magistrats grâce aux travaux préparatoir
qui ont été conduits dans la mission que
vous avez mené madame la Présidente côté
de la députée Émilie chandlerur on est
passé
d'une proposition de loi je m'y arrête
un quart de seconde qui tendait à
créer des tribunaux spécialisés
à avec un travail qui était qui n'était
pas achevé qui n'était pas abouti les
magistrats étaient totalement hostiles à
cette création en revanche ils ont parf
parfitement accueilli les pôle
[Musique]
spécialisé si on peut résumer ce que
sont ces ple spécialisé bonjour monsieur
le sénateur c'est en
réalité l'idée que on ne peut plus et
qu'on ne peut pas fonctionner en silo et
que tout le monde doit se
parler force de sécurité intérieure
évidemment mais aussi parquet juge
d'application des peines juge aux
affaires familiales et ceter et cetera
c'est l'antiérgac si je je je puis euh
me permettre de de résumer les
choses j'ai souhaité m'inspirer de vos
recommandations pour consacrer
l'articulation indispensable entre
procédure civile et procédures pénales
ça aussi c'était deux silos
distincts qui fonctionnaient en
parallèle et qui mérite grâce à une
organisation dédiée et spécialisée de de
se parler et d'échanger on évite à
l'évidence des situations qui sont
dramatiques et
irréversibles fait ces pô spécialisé
constituent un message très fort envoyé
à toutes les
victimes qui mérite bien sûr un
accompagnement spécifique et un jugement
adapté à la complexité de ces
violences souligner madame la Présidente
l'importance de la formation de tous les
acteurs judiciaires
et l'exemple que vous nous avez donné
illustre à quel
point il y a encore dans les esprits des
choses qui mériteraient d'être balayé si
j'ose dire d'un d'un vrai rever de
manche pour pas dire d'un d'un grand
coup de balai mais
mais retenir que il y a aussi beaucoup
de bonne volonté que naturellement les
formation des enquêteurs des magistrats
des greffiers des avocats également et
de tous les partenaires je pense aux
associations je pense aux soignant je
pense aux services sociaux tout cela est
absolument indispensable et je partage
totalement votre préoccupation que j'ai
souhaité d'ailleurs consacrer dans une
circulaire que j'ai signé en novembre le
24 novembre 2023 ainsi les membres des
pôles spécialisés participons à des
actions de formation local organisées au
plus proche et au plus près des acteurs
de terrain ce qui intègre évidemment
toutes les évolutions récentes
normatives et les nouveaux outils de
protection les magistrats euh vont
pouvoir s'appuyer sur des moyens
numériques dédiés avec l'applicatif
sispop système informatisé de suivi de
politique pénale prioritaire euh
autorisé par décret du 10 octobre 2023
euh cet outil
indispensable centralise l'ensemble des
données relativ aux situations
familiales issu à la fois des procédures
civiles mais aussi des procédures
pénales et les informations échangé dans
le
cadre des comités de pilotage il est
doté de fonctionnalité de pilotage des
mesures de protection de mécanismes
d'alerte automatisé et
personnalisable de radars en matière de
protection de l'enfance ou
lors de la sortie de détention ce qui
était une préoccupation très très forte
évidemment des
victimes qui ne peuvent pas vivre dans
la crainte tout simplement
exprimer vous l'avez relevé madame la
Présidente l'intervention judiciaire en
matière de vif est très dépendante de la
réactivité de ses partenaires et ça
implique évidemment une coordination
interministérielle à tous les
niveaux bien sûr une coordination à un
niveau politique c'est bien bien le sens
du plan gouvernemental renouvelé le 8
mars dernier désormais piloté par ma
collègue Aurore berger dont la
détermination je le crois est connue de
toutes et de
tous quatre axes majeurs lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes égalité
professionnelle économique santé des
femmes et la culture de l'égalité qui
engage évidemment toutes nos
administrations sans exception alors
j'entends votre inquiétude sur la
réalité de cette coordination et je veux
vous assurer que nous avons engagé une
profonde révolution
euh je vous le dis sans coordination
effective nous ne serions jamais
parvenus à déployer 5500 TGD en 2023
contre seulement je vous demande de
retenir ce chiffre 976 en 2020 allez
évolution elle est extrêmement
importante plus
de plus de 1000 barres en seulement 2
ans 145 unités d'accueil pédiatrique
enfants sans danger pour protéger les
enfants
covictime nous avions envisagé un nuaped
par département nous souhaitons
désormais un nuaped par ressort
judiciaire dont il est vrai que c'est un
outil
absolument performant dont plus personne
ne pourrait songer
à à se
passer nous ne serions jamais parvenus à
absorber une augmentation de plus de 123
% du nombre de condamnations des auteurs
impliquant une prise en charge
disciplinaire s'il y avait pas cette
mobilisation totale alors de nombreuses
instructions conjointes engageant
plusieurs ministères vu le jour et sont
autant d'illustration de cette
coordination circulaire
interministérielle du 25 novembre 2021
ayant permis les dépôts de plaines et le
recueil de preuves au sein des
établissements de
santé bon l'utilité je je veux pas m'y
arrêter tout le monde imagine que c'est
extrêmement douloureux de devoir répéter
les choses et cetera en réalité c'est
les enquêteurs c'est la justice c'est la
médecine médecine
légale qui vient vers la victime et pas
l'inverse et c'est une
évolution
majeur dans les pratiques qui sont les
nôtres dans le prolongement j'ai signé
en mai 2000 23 la convention permettant
le déploiement national d'un lieu de
prise en charge globale des victimes à
l'instar du dispositif maison des femmes
au côté des ministres de l'intérieur et
du ministre de la
Santé circulaire d'avril
2022 conjointe là encore signé avec le
ministère de la Santé permettant le
déploiement du protocole féminicide
consacré à la prise en charge immédiate
des enfants
présents pendant le pendant le
drame témoin de ces violences et cet
enfant témoin est est devenu un enfant
victime euh je me souviens de ce que
dit culnique qui dit qu'un enfant qui
assiste à des
violences subit un traumatisme digne de
d'une scène de guerre en réalité son
psychisme est évidemment totalement
déchiré par ce qu'il par ce dont il a
été le témoin chaque avancé dans le
champ judiciaire et est systématiquement
intégré dans une action coordonnée avec
mes autres collègues du gouvernement et
ma priorité je je veux le redire
ici absolu est une bonne application des
lois par le ministère de la Justice
évidemment et par l'ensemble des
services de l'État cette articulation
interministérielle est en outre garantie
au sein du ministère de la Justice grâce
à un pilotage interne que j'ai confié à
la haute fonctionnaire à l'égalité des
droits dont la Cour des comptes a salué
le positionnement à haut
niveau pas tous les jours qu'on reçoit
des compliments de la Cour des comptes
et donc quand on reçoit des compliments
de la Cour des comptes il faut savoir
les apprécier à leur juste très juste
valeur un mot madame la Présidente si
vous me le permettez sur la lutte contre
les violences sexuelles et
sexiste depuis 2017 la France est
pleinement engagée politiquement comme
juridiquement dans la mise en œuvre
concrète d'une législation sévère et et
efficace pour réprimer toutes les formes
de violence sexuelle avec la
détermination et la rigueur
nécessaire vous avez voté des avancées
législatives qui à mes yeux sont
déterminantes qui confortent la place de
la France pour faire avancer les droits
des victimes de violence sexuelle je
pense en particulier à la loi du 3 août
2018 qui a renforcé la répression du
cyber
euh du cyber harcèlement et cré les
infractions d'outrage sexiste ainsi que
le délit de voyurisme je pense aussi à
la loi du 21 avril
2021 porté par madame la sénatrice
billon qui renforce la protection des
mineurs victimes sans renverser la
charge de la preuve en fixant un âge
endessin duquel un mineur ne peut
consentir un acte
sexuel je prendre ici un instant pour
éclairer les controverses qui conduisent
de manière à mon sens injustifiée à
conclure à l'inaction de notre
justice depuis
2017 le nombre d'affaires nouvelles de
viol porté la connaissance des
procureurs de la République est en
constante
augmentation ainsi 23000
personnes ont été mises en cause dans
des affaires de viol orientés par les
parquets en 2022
contre
1294 une
affaire personne mise en cause
pardonnez-moi en 2017 c'est précisément
une augmentation de 104
%. lorsque les faits sont caractérisés
et l'auteur identifié la réponse pénale
est je le dis
systématique j'ai donné des février 2021
instruction au procureur de poursuivre
l'enquête y
compris mesdames monsieur le sénateur
lorsque les faits apparaissent prescrits
ce qui
permet de
découvrir d'autres
victimes le nombre de condamnations de
majeur pour viol a augmenté de 30 %
depuis
2017 passant de 960 en 2017 à
120060 en
2022 le nombre de condamnations de
majeur pour agression sexuelle était de
5617 en 2017 il est de
485 en 2022 et la progression est encore
plus importante s'agissant des
condamnations pour viol incestueux
commis sur un
mineur c'est une progression de 129 %
entre 2017 et 2021 passant de 177 à 405
les condamnations pour agression
sexuelle inestueuse ou atteinte sexuelle
incestueuse ont progressé quant à elle
de 91 % passant de
675 à
90 un dernier chiffre sur le quantum des
peines prononcées en matière de viol il
est de 11 ans en
moyenne et c'est un des quantum les plus
importants les plus élevés
d'Europe enfin je veux indiquer qu'il
est impossible en l'état de nos données
d'établir un pourcentage de classement
comparer le nombre de plaintes et de
condamnation est lusoir car ce ne sont
pas les mêmes procédures qui sont
comptabilisées et ce serait nié les
exigences probatoire fondamental dans
notre État de droit permettant de
poursuivre et de condamner évidemment
les auteurs on peut pas conclure à
l'inaction de la justice ni à son
impunité les chiffres en sont me
semble-t-il les pousstoufflantes
démonstration et je veux mettre en garde
tous ceux qui publiquement tiennent ce
discours mais au-delà de la critique on
est habitué à être critiqué mais ce qui
me chagrine le plus c'est que c'est
susceptible de décourager bon nombre de
victimes qui se finalement qu'on laisse
dans une espèce d'aquabonisme ah ben ça
sert à rien parce que la justice ne
condamne pas parce que la justice
n'enquête pas parce que la justice et
cetera je vous ai donné un certain
nombre de chiffres je souhaite vraiment
mettre un terme à à à à ces choses qui
sont dites et qui ont surtout comme
effet délétaire et dévastateur le fait
de
démobiliser des victimes qui
souhaiteraient déposer plainte et qui se
disent à quoi bon ce discours est un
discours absolument contreproductif
entendre à longueur de plateau de télé
porter plainte ça sert à rien que la
justice fait
rien quel est l'xiste voilà c'est
absolument insupportable ça n'est pas
conforme à la
et moi je veux dire aux victimes portez
plainte et saisissez la justice
évidemment tout n'est pas
parfait mais nous faisons tout j'allais
dire tous ensemble pour que les choses
bougent et qu'elles ailleent dans le bon
sens on doit poursuivre les efforts pour
accueillir la parole des victimes pour
la respecter l'accueillir et la
respecter et pour moi les choses vont
évidemment de de paire du dépôt de la
plainte à l'issue de la procédure pénale
et il faut évidemment redonner aux
victimes confiance dans l'institution
judiciaire on a des résultats avec la
mise en place des cours criminelles
départementales partie des questions que
légitimement madame la Présidente vous
me posez dont la généralisation je
rappelle est effective depuis janvier
2023 on sait déjà
que les crimes sexuels qui constituent
90 % des affaires envoyé devant les
Cours criminelles sont jugés plus vite
et permettent de faire baisser les
correctionnalisations
correctionnalisation pour une victime
c'est insupportable
elle sait ce qu'elle a vécu elle a vécu
un viol c'est comme ça que c'est fait
mérite d'être qualifié et on dit à un
moment à la victime mais vous allez être
jugé devant le tribunal correctionnel
c'est quelque chose que les victimes ne
supportent pas et on peut en
entendre leur désarroi leur
désappointement je crois d'ailleurs que
les mots ne sont pas justes la moyenne
du délai d'audiencement mesames les
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur des
dossiers d'accusés détenus est en effet
de 5 de 6 pardonnez-moi vir5 mois et de
8,7 mois pour les accusés libres ce qui
est particulièrement bref au regard en
particulier des 18 mois en en moyenne du
délai d'audiencement aux assises si
j'ose dire classique sur les h premiers
cours les h premières courses
expérimentales
euh on a remarqué une augmentation des
décisions criminelles rendu de plus de
50 % et c'est un chiffre énorme et je
précise que le taux d'acquitement est le
même que pour les cours d'assise environ
5 % c'estàd que sur le terrain
probatoire nous sommes à égalité entre
euh euh ces deux
juridictions évidemment on n'a pas
achevé notre mission pour mieux protéger
les victim en amont et en aval de
l'intervention de la
justice et depuis 3 ans euh j'ai porté
une augmentation des moyens consacrés à
l'aide aux victimes euh au profit de nos
associations partenaires vous avez ainsi
voté un budget alloué à l'aide aux
victimes de 47 millions en
2024 contre 26 millions en 2017 c'est
une augmentation de 80 %. alors faut-il
changer à nouveau la loi pénale au
regard des débats actuels sur la
définition du viol les débats récent
parfois virulent impose de livrer une
lecture honnête et rigoureuse sur notre
législation d'abord la législation
française en matière de viol est sans
doute la plus répressive
d'Europe 15 ans de réclusion criminelle
jusqu'à la
perpétuité avec un certain nombre de
circonstances aggravantes lorsque
l'Espagne qui est toujours une référence
fixe une peine de 6 à 12 ans depuis
2022 notre définition du viol protège
les victimes et permet de sanctionner
lourdement les auteurs s'attachant à
démontrer la responsabilité de la
agresseur qui impose une relation
sexuelle non consentie le juge est
évidemment le garant de la liberté et
notre droit permet de condamner
lourdement en appréciant concrètement
l'absence de consentement des victimes
la preuve est rapportée par l'accusation
et par personne d'autre est-ce le rôle
de la loi pénale que de définir le
consentement d'une victime au lieu de
s'attacher à définir la responsabilité
du criminel voilà comment les choses
méritent d'être dites et les questions
méritent d'être posées avec des risques
de glissement vers une
contractualisation des relations
sexuelles dont je le crois personne ne
veut et je veux ici mettre en garde
quand au risque de braquer la
focale sur la victime alors que le seul
responsable c'est le violeur le risque
majeur est de faire peser la preuve du
consentement sur la
victime aussi moi j'appelle à la plus
grande prudence ce que veulent les
et nous devons y répondre c'est des
procédures plus rapides des procédures
compréhensible une meilleure information
à tous les stades de la
procédure mais également une information
pour le grand public qui peut désormais
appréhender la complexité de ses
affaires grâce à une loi que vous avez
porté qui permet de filmer les audience
qui permet certain nombre de nos
compatriotes de bien comprendre ce que
sont les mécanismes judiciaire la
difficulté de rendre la justice c'est
toujours mieux que le prisme de la fé
diversification qu'on nous offre en 35
secondes sur certaines chaînes pour dire
que la justice ne fonctionne pas en
général d'ailleurs ce sont pas des
juristes qui font les commentaires peu
importe je ferme la parenthèse il est
intéressant de savoir que le fait de que
la justice se donne à voir permet de
mieux l'appréhender de mieux la
comprendre et de la critiquer d'une
façon qui n'est pas une façon niéiste
prise en charge globale des auteurs car
les violences faites aux femmes qu'elles
soitent intimes ou sur la voie publique
appellent des réponses spécifiques
intégrant des démarches de
soin je voudrais vous convaincre de ma
totale détermination à combler toutes
les failles ou lacunes relevant tant des
pratiques professionnelles que de la
loi encore une fois bon chaque
infraction chaque viol chaque féminicide
euh est un échec pour toute notre notre
société
euh mais chaque
plainte transmise au parquet est en soit
un progrès et si la justice n'est pas
saisie je l'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est
une évidence mais parfois il faut redire
les évidences la JCE n'est pas dit
naturellement elle ne peut pas
intervenir alors la justice n'a pas d'
priori dans notre pays souvent lorsque
les procédures sont classées bah
disonsle c'est faute de preuve pas
comment faute d'identification de
l'auteur tout cela c'est une constante
c'est tout un système probatoire c'est
c'est l'état de droit c'est le
fonctionnement judiciaire tel
que tel qu'il doit être consacré et ça
ne veut pas dire que les faits n'ont pas
eu lieu mais simplement qu'ils n'ont pas
pu être démontré en justice et il nous
faut inciter les victimes à déposer
plainte le plus vite possible pour cela
et ducons nos enfants et tous les
adultes à identifier toutes les
situations de violence sexuelle car nous
disposons je je je pense d'un vaste
arsenal législatif
pour y répondre alors s'agissant de la
position de la France sur la directive
européenne en
réalité il s'agit d'un débat de
compétence alors je sais que certains
ont instrumentalisé ce
débat pour dire que la France ne voulait
pas que la France n'avait pas envie que
la France était
rétrograde c'est d'abord c'est surtout
et c'est à nos yeux uniquement un débat
de compéten c'est un débat de de de de
compétence de l'Union et un débat de
doctrine et on va le dire très
clairement les
juristes ne sont pas d'accord entre eux
il est tout à fait clair qu'à ce stade
des
négociation il est primordial de ne
prendre aucun risque
sur un texte qui pourrait être annulé
par la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne et plutôt que d'avoir avancé
encore que je le dis notre législation
est la plus répressive d'Europe les
femmes alors aurait beaucoup perdu parce
que si le texte devait être censuré et
bien ceux qui je le redis parfois des
fins politiciennes instrumentalistes
débat
serait les responsables d'un recul
absolument historique que moi je
n'envisage pas une
seconde de de supporter nous avons une
législation nous sommes très clairs dans
notre
législation prendre des risques et
encourir la censure de la Cour de
justice de
l'Union c'est un risque que moi je ne
veut pas prendre les femmes ont besoin
de sécurité juridique le texte européen
comporte des avancées
majeures qu'il ne faut pas
fragiliser
j'aimerais à
présent évoquer un chantier historique
qui est celui de l'inscription de l'IVG
dans notre
Constitution j'auris honneur de me
présenter devant vous
prochainement avec ce projet de loi
constitutionnel relatif à la liberté de
recourir à
l'interruption à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse adopté il y a
quelques jours par l'Assemblée nationale
euh à une majorité c'est un petit clin
d'œil badin que je vous adresse non pas
des 3/5e mais des
[Musique]
9/10è ce projet il est à l'évidence un
point d'équilibre entre les nombreux
travaux qui ont été engagés dans les
deux chambres et le
Sénat a été c'est bien
normal plus que respecté dans la
préparation de cette version de
compromis comment puis-je le dire
simplement euh l'écriture proposée par
le gouvernement est à 95 %
celle du
Sénat je dis 95 pour faire chiffre
rond pourra dire
[Musique]
98,5 donc on a entendu le scénat
évidemment on a deux textes qui sont
différents on a cherché le point
d'équilibre le point de
compromis je pense que
l'enjeu ne permett
aucune instrumentalisation politicienne
et je
n'envisage en aucune
façon
que de telles choses puissent traverser
les
esprits le projet de loi il comporte une
disposition unique qui a pour objet de
modifier l'article 34 de la Constitution
en y ajoutant après le 17e
alinéa un alinéa ainsi rédigé la
loi détermine les conditions dans
lesquell s'exerce la liberté garantie à
la femme d'avoir recours à une
interruption volontaire de
grossesse je veux rassurer toutes celles
et tous ceux qui craignent que ce projet
ne consacre un droit absolu et sans
limite non ça n'est évidemment pas ce
que nous
voulons non ce n'est pas ce que fait le
le terme
garantie seule concession faite à
l'Assemblée
nationale seul com je disais tout à
l'heure 95 % peut augmenter encore le
chiffre n'emporte pas la création d'un
droit opposable absolu sans limite et ça
n'est pas moi mesdames les sénatrices
monsieur sénateur qui le dit c'est le
Conseil d'État dans un avis
dont je vous recommande à
toutes à vous monsieur le sénateur la
lecture parce qu'il est particulièrement
étayé il précise que j'ouvre les
guillemets à cet instant par elle-même
l'inscription de la liberté de recourir
à une IVG dans la Constitution dans les
termes que propose le gouvernement ne
remet pas en cause les autres droits et
que la Constitution garantit tel que
notamment la liberté de conscience qui
soutend la liberté des médecins et sages
femmes de ne pas pratiquer une IVG ainsi
que la liberté d'expression et par
ailleurs je veux que la liberté de
recourir à
l'IVG je constate que cette liberté n'a
pas été consacrée au niveau constit
tionnelle contrairement d'ailleurs à ce
que l'on pourrait penser d'emblé il y a
toute une analyse du Conseil d'État qui
rappelle que tant sur le plan national
que que supranational Convention
européenne de sauvegarde des droits de
l'homme jurisprudence de la Cour
européenne jurisprudence de la Cour de
justice la loi veille n'est pas
constitutionnellement protégée
voilà cette analyse encore une fois elle
n'est pas mienne elle n'est pas
partisane
elle est le fruit d'une
réflexion portée par le Conseil d'État
et exprimée en des termes qui sont des
termes je les ai qualifié comme tel et
je le refais en des termes
lumineux
alors le Conseil
d'État nous rappelle qu'en revanche le
principe de sauvegarde de la dignité de
la personne humaine a été
consacré comme principe à valeur
constitutionnelle par une décision du
Conseil constitutionnel de
1994 et qu'il en va de même du principe
de liberté de conscience des médecins
consacré comme principe fondamental
reconnu par les lois de la République
par une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel de
2001 dignité de la personne consacrée au
plus haut niveau liberté de conscience
consacrée au plus haut niveau et
liberté garantie à la femme d'avorter
euh ne serait pas protégé de la même
façon comprenez bien que dans le
triptique là euh il nous manque un
élément et cet élément c'est la
protection constitutionnelle que je
souhaiterais que nous euh puissions tous
ensemble de façon transpartisane
euh mettre en œuvre et mettre en place
et pour dire les choses
clairement la sauvegarde de la dignité
humaine la liberté de conscience des
médecins ont déjà valeurs
constitutionnelles
voilà et la liberté d'avoir recours à
l'IVG
non
bon cette seule question
et et la réponse à cette seule question
devrait me semble-t-il nous inciter à
adopter le texte alors j'entends
évidemment les craintes quant à notre
Constitution qui deviendrait selon une
formule désormais consacrée un catalogue
s cohérence des droits sociaux et
sociét bon très
clairement sur ces
sujets
sociétau
philosophique je respecte évidemment
l'opinion de toutes et de tous pas
contraindre les
consciences je pense que nous le savons
la liberté de penser c'est quelque chose
qui est important pour
autant la institution pardon de le dire
ainsi dispose déjà de
nombreux droits et libertés et c'est
même une de ses fonctions majeures
réunir l'ensemble des droits et
libertés particulièrement
important la seule question qui vous
sera posée le 28 février prochain c'est
la liberté de recourir à l'IVG
recouvre-t-elle à vos yeux une
importance suffisante pour être protégé
par notre Constitution voilà comment
à ce
stade je me permets de poser la la
question et c'est à vous en tant que
constituant qu'il appartiendra bien sûr
de de répondre et vous l'aurez compris
en ce qui me concerne la réponse c'est
oui et à ceux qui répondent que l'IVG
n'est pas menacé en France je dis que on
nécrit pas la Constitution pour le
présent on l'écrit d'abord et surtout
pour l'avenir et c'est le propre même de
notre loi suprême
elle a pour vocation à duré
elle a pour vocation de de valoir pour
l'avenir en protégeant évidemment nos
droits mais en regardant
vers un horizon qui peut-être un horizon
éloigné et les expériences
étrangères en la matière nous démontre
que rien n'est acquis
voilà pas revenir sur ce qui s'est passé
outre
atlantique revenir sur ce qui s'est
passé en Europe où l'on a contraint des
femmes à entendre les battement de cœur
de du fetus qu'elle portait pour les
dissuader d'avorter à mes yeux une
torture
insupportable alors vous m'avez posé une
question précise madame la Présidente
s'agissant du calendrier alors j'ai
précisé lors du vote de l'Assemblée
nationale il y a quelques jours que nous
prendrions le temps et qu'il faut aller
au bout de cette révision alors je sais
les
mois qui a pu provoquer l'évocation
d'une date de congrès avant même que les
chambres ne se soi prononcer
oui mais je je je je avant de dire que
c'est pas malin que je voudrais je
voudrais vous dire deux mots là-dessus
sur l'expression non non mais sur sur
les choses qui ont été dites et en
particulier sur les choses qui ont été
dites par le Président de la
République ces choses elles ont été
dites monsieur le sénateur lors des
rencontres de Saint-Denis et le
président de la République dit
précisément
ceci un examen dans chaque assemblée
pourra avoir
lieu au premier trimestre
2024 afin qu'un conte
puisse être
envisagé le 4 mars
alors le 4 mars prochain mais pardon
vous dites c'est pas malin et moi je dis
et moi je dis c'est à la fois
respectueux et prudent bon voilà mais
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que
franchement
alors une perception des choses
naturellement pour le coup différente et
partisan mais est-ce que ça
mérite que cette
réforme ne soit pas envisagée pour des
questions de c'est pas
malin moi je dis c'est c'était très
prudent je je je je vous ai relu
exactement ce que le président de la
République a exprimé est-ce que sur une
réforme aussi importante que celle-là
sur une liberté aussi importante que
celle-là pour toutes les femmes de notre
pays le fait que nous soyons si alors je
je je vais y mettre je vais abandonner
le le le mode indicatif monsieur le
sénateur pour ne pas vous froisser
utiliser tous les conditionnels qui vont
bien tous les si toutes les virgules
tous les trois points de suspension ok
mais franchement de quoi parle-t-on on
parle d'une liberté fondamentale pour
les femmes et puis et puis nous serions
le le premier pays à inscrire cela dans
notre
Constitution bon voilà après chacun sera
avec sa conscience et moi je ne veux pas
violer les consciences je n'en ai pas
les moyens je suis parfaitement
respectueux du travail
parlementaire je peux rien vous dire
d'autre VO mesurons les
enjeux nous avons des choses d'ors et
déjà garanties par notre Constitution
sauf l'essentiel qui est la liberté de
la femme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure dans
dans ce dans ce triptique que je regarde
avec beaucoup d'objectivité c'est un
travail de de d'analyse auquel
d'ailleurs a procédé le Conseil d'État
je trouve assez désolant
que nous ne consacrions pas mais j'ai la
conviction
que au-delà des
susceptibilités qui peuvent s'exprimer
au
fond et heureusement qu'elle
s'exprime nous irons vers les essenti et
l'essentiel c'est de garantir aux femmes
une liberté qui est celle de disposer de
leur corps ah pas plus compliqué que ça
bon donc moi je veux vous rassurer
madame la Présidente mais je pense que
vous n'êtes pas inquiète on prendra le
temps qu'il faudra pour aller au bout de
cette révision parce que je pense
profondément qu'elle est indispensable
voilà euh je veux redire ici que nous
avons tout fait mais vraiment tout fait
pour que l'écriture proposée dans ce
projet de révision soit accepté par une
majorité de sénateurs parce que ce
projet c'est pas une initiative du
gouvernement seul vous le savez il
arrive après de nombreuses initiatives
parlementaires neuf initiatives
parlementaires je crois bon
euh nous nous sommes dans une forme
nous non non mais euh et je dis le
contraire d'ailleurs on parle
d'initiative parlementa nous nous avions
dit dans un premier temps le président
de la République avait dit nous
regardons les initiatives parlementaires
et puis nous nous nous ferons quelque
chose de cela
bon au fond mais je ne veux Horter
aucune sensibilité c'est une forme de 3è
lecture et le gouvernement a pris je
l'ai déjà dit la quasi intégralité de
l'écriture du Sénat alors moi je dis
tout simplement faut pas rater ce moment
il faut pas rater cette alignement des
planètes et pour conclure je je je veux
saluer madame la Présidente je pense
avoir été complet sur cette question je
veux saluer les les travaux en cours qui
sont mené par votre délégation
relativement au familles
monoparental réalité sociale elle touche
très majoritairement les femmes et elles
accentuent évidemment leur précarisation
et tout cela doit être pris en compte
dans le traitement judiciaire alors vous
m'interrogez sur les ité
jurisprudentielle ainsi que sur le
faible montant de la pension alimentaire
fixé judiciairement bon le juge aux
affair familiales il se fondent sur des
critères qui ont été fixés par la
loi pardonnez-moi par la loi notamment
c'est l'article
371- 2 de notre Code civil pour
déterminer le montant de la contribution
à l'entretien et l'éducation des
enfants ressources du parent déb
et du parent créancier charge du parent
débiteur du parent créancier besoin de
l'enfant et afin d'accompagner le juge
dans la fixation du montant de cette
contribution un référentiel indicatif
fait l'objet d'une diffusion publique
accessible au justiciable c'est un
simulateur qui est accessible sur notre
site Internet ainsi que
sur toute nouvelle application
justice.fr que je vous recommande de
télécharger et au total ce sont plus de
1000 personnes par jour qui utilisent ce
simulateur
c'est une petite fierté que de l'avoir
mise en place il y a des femmes qui
aujourd'hui on le sait
euh ne peuvent pas ne veulent pas
n'osent pas quitter un conjoint avec
lequel elles
vivent des jours bien tristes euh parce
qu'elles se disent mais comment je vais
faire pour élever les gamin et cet outil
permet aux femmes d'avoir une simulation
immédiate de ce à quoi elle pourrait
prétendre en terme de pension
alimentaire alors ça ne règle pas la
question du rééquilibrage je dois dire
mais vous le savez toutes et tous
que le garde saau ne peut pas donner de
directive peut pas le faire auprès d'un
procureur moins encore auprès d'un juge
du siège mais on peut en revanche
attirer l'attention et c'est aussi notre
rôle aujourd'hui sur les disparités il y
a aucune raison effectivement que les
femmes
soient les victimes au fond d'une
jurisprudence qui ne prendrait pas en
considération la réalité des éléments
pécunires que vous nous avez raelé tout
à l'heure aucune raison
euh je quand même parler une toute
petite seconde et puis ensuite je
réponds pardon il y a quelques questions
effectiv j'imagine je je trai très vite
il me reste quelques mots je ve quand
même rappeler l'intermédiation des
pensions alimentaires qui est quand même
quelque chose qui a été fait en en
faveur des femmes et qui et qui change
leur vie j'ai j'ai rencontré moi-même
dans différents déplacements que j'ai pu
faire à la C notamment des femmes qui
mais avaiit àaire
à des paires qui parfois avaient oublié
les obligations qui sont les leurs
l'intermédiation pension alimentaire
c'est quand même un un un progrès permet
vous le savez de de sécuriser chaque
mois le versement de la pension
alimentaire en prévenant le risque
d'impayer en 2022 je vous donne ce
chiffre j'ai pratiquement terminé 200
millions d'euros ont été recouvrés par
l'ARIPA la précarisation des femmes qui
représente 82 % des familles
monoparentales c'est un enjeu majeur
pour notre
société et ça nécessite une réponse
global pour les soutenir je suivrai
ainsi avec la plus grande attention vos
travaux vos
recommandations pour en assurer une
parfaite diffusion au sein de
l'institution judiciaire ce qui sera
sans aucun doute l'occasion de redire
vos préoccupations quant au
déséquilibre jurisprudentiel qui peut
nître parfois pour la fixation des
pensions alimentaires voilà madame la
Présidente Mesdames les sénatrices
monsieur sénateur je suis à votre
disposition pour répondre à toutes les
questions des membres de votre
délégation merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre pour ce point très exhaustif je
sais que mes collègues brûlent de vous
poser des questions donc je vous poserai
les miennes qu'
qu'après je donne la parole tout d'abord
à anque billon suivrons ensuite Laurence
Rossignol puis Joseline
Antoine merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le garde d' saau pour cette
audition devant notre délégation au
droits des femmes ça me donne l'occasion
de de vous remercier pour à la fois
l'engagement que vous avez pris depuis
la prise de fonction en tant que garde
d' saau pour la lutte contre les
violences intrafamiliales et finalement
ça fait écho à à la discussion générale
hier de notre président Hervé Marseille
dans le travail de conoconstruction la
loi que j'ai porté en 2021 effectivement
elle elle elle a été coconstruite grâce
à ce travail que nous avons eu ensemble
et je vous en remercie sur d'abord sur
sur l'IVG euh bien entendu et comme
depuis euh toutes ces discussions que
nous avons pu avoir au sein de la
délégation et dans l'hémicycle sur la
constitutionnalisation je voterai
favorablement en faveur de la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG euh oui
il y a peut-être eu une maladresse de
calendrier euh nous avons eu l'occasion
d'en débattre déjà longuement donc je
pense que le débat a été déjà assez
riche et et je je reste attaché à
forcément à ce droit fondamental pour
moi c'est un droit fondamental pour les
générations à venir et je suis heureuse
d'entendre ce matin votre détermination
peut-être revenir d'abord sur les
ordonnances de protection puisque en
novembre 2023 berangè Couillard
annonçait qu'elles allaient passer à 24h
et la requérante d'une ordonnance de
protection doit apporter la preuve de la
vraisemblance des violences et de
l'actualité du danger ce sont ces
preuves qui doivent car ériser de
manière indupitable l'existence de
violence et donc de danger et et là
c'est pas toujours le cas ces critères
posent des des enfin on a du mal à
appréhender ces critères et donc parfois
le véritable danger est quelque chose
une notion un petit peu flou et or les
les victimes sont en fait déjà en
danger de mort
parfois l'examen de la proposition de
loi d'Émilie chandleur suite au rapport
rougeevf porté avec notre présidente euh
a démontré l'utilité de raccourcir ses
délais donc moi j'ai quelques question
qu'en est-il de l'efficacité de
l'ordonnance de protection combien de
victimes en bénéficiie et comptez-vous
revoir les critères de l'ordonnance de
protection vous avez évoqué la médecine
légale on sait qu'elle joue un rôle
considérable dans l'accompagnement des
victimes mais aussi pour détecter les
victimes et pour les enquêteurs euh je
vais parler de laav vender en 2021
l'équivalent temps plein c'était 0,8
équivalent temps plein euh il y avait
1200 actes de réalisé quand il y en
aurait pu en avoir 3000 pour le cas des
violences intrafamiliales donc quid de
la situation dans les autres département
et avez-vous imaginé revoir ce ce ces
équivalents en plein leur nombre pour
avoir une vraie médecine légale dans les
départements la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes depuis 2017
et la annonce du président de la
République a pris une tournure
importante dans dans notre travail à la
fois législatif et dans la société la
libération de la parole des enfants a
pris elle un tour important au moment de
la création de la civise et euh la
civise a permis de libérer cette parole
des victimes mineures euh le départ
forcé du
co-président Édouard le juge Édouard
Durand a créé beaucoup d'émois beaucoup
de de d'inquiétude par rapport à à cette
à cette formidable euh je dirais euh à
cet engouement et cette libération de la
parole des victimes donc je le rappelle
160000 victeur victimes mineures euh
tous les ans alors qu'avez-vous imaginé
pour lutter efficacement contre les
agressions sur mineur tout le monde
savait mais en général c'est tellement
inconcevable que personne le révèle
comment et avec quel outil mieux prendre
en compte la parole des enfants et euh
il y a un sujet qui revient
régulièrement c'est
l'imprescriptibilité alors que nous
avions voté des dispositions finalement
avec la prescriptibilité glissante
est-ce que c'est un sujet sur lesquel
vous vous réfléchissez ou vous vous
n'avez pas bougé de position euh
peut-être pour finir puisque je sais que
le temps est est compté madame la
Présidente euh les femmes dans un petit
sujet plus léger on va dire femmes dans
les professions judiciaires puisque nous
avons porté avec ma ma collègue et
présidente Dominique Verrien une
proposition de loi sur la place des
femmes dans dans les dans la haute
fonction publique et donc cette place
des femmes dans les postes à
responsabilité alors les femmes sont de
plus en plus nombreuses dans les
professions judiciaires
donc en 2016 une étude demandée par le
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature
constatait que la position de chef de
juridiction montre une forte masse
masculinisation tout à fait atypique eu
égard à la féminisation du corps au 1er
janvier 2023 71 % des juges en France
sont des femmes donc la magistrature est
aujourd'hui une profession non mixte
finalement mais pour autant les postes
de responsabilité eux sont
essentiellement occupés par des hommes
donc ben quelle solution quelle
qu'est-ce que vous avez imaginé pour que
les femmes occupent plus plus de
responsabilité aussi dans la profession
dans les professions judiciaires je vous
remercie j'ai fait aussi vite
quead de justice vous remercie je passe
la parole à Laurence
Rossignol merci madame la Présidente une
question une remarque et une précision
historique et je commencerai d'abord par
dire que je j'adhère au propos du garde
des saau les choses avancent voilà c'est
incontestable elles avancent dans la
justice je peux vous signer si vous
voulez non non c'est vrai je je vois que
vos collaborateurs sourit euh bonne
journée bonne
journée Sénat c'est pas une bonne
journée c'est une bonne
semaine non non mais c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est incontestable et je je
partage bon nombre des des remarques des
discussions qui restent encore en cours
et je les questions de de définition du
viol sont piégeuses parce que je ne
crois pas qu'aucune définition nous met
à l'abri d'un débat sur le consentement
dans les cours voilà c'est ni celle
d'aujourd'hui ni celle ni une autre et
que par ailleurs je pense aussi qu'
notre définition est bien on pourrait
peut-être y ajouter une définition de ce
qu'est le viol qui dirait le viol est
une relation sexuelle non consentie
voilà ça ça nuirait pas ça ne nuirait
pas et ça
conserverait l'article tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui ceci étant posé ma question
va être plus précise et plus technique
je crois les con criminels départemental
ont effectivement des des résultats
c'est vrai pour autant je me demande si
c'est la
meilleure instance pour toutes les
affaires je pense en particulier vous
savez que la délégation Dr des femmes du
Sénat est très soucieuse des suites des
affaires sur la pornographie le pret
French le procet French bkque va arriver
probablement 2025 me dit-on maintenant
et à cet instant il est envoyé devant
une cour criminelle départementale je ne
suis pas sûr que ce soit le bon endroit
euh voilà mais c'est le seul possible
dans la loi aujourd'hui j'y viens
monsieur garde des saut seriez-vous
d'accord à pour soutenir une proposition
de loi qui en fait étendraiit les cours
d'assise spécialisé aux affaires de
traite des êtres humains en bande
organisée puisqueaujourd'hui les cours
d'assis
spécialisé sont compétentes pour les
affaires de terrorisme et pour les
affaires de trafic de stupéfiants en
bande organisée est-ce que le trafic la
traite des êtres humains en bande
organisé pourrait être une de compétence
des cours d'assis spécialisé et
peut-être aussi des viols criels je me
suis m'était fait la remarque au moment
où il y a eu le procès dans le Vaucluse
de cet homme où il y avait 51 prévenus
si ma mémoire est bonne d'un viol sériel
celui qui s'est daté sa femme et
peut-être ça aa a mérité et sur les
affaires de de de traite des êtres
humains et les affaires
pardon
Avignon en le le les faits étaient dans
le
V celui qui drogit sa
femme voilà c'est celui-là bref pe peu
importe et donc je je je me disais que
sur les affaires French Bouake puis
après on en aura d'autres affaires
concernant les viols dans la industrie
pornographique un deuxième procès qui
vient derrière peut-être la cour
d'assise spécialement composée serait la
bonne voilà je vous demande pas de
répondre à cette question là à cet
instant parce qu'elle demande
effectivement d'être expertisé et de
travailler euh sur l'IVG la
constionnalisation de
l'IVG je c'est plus à mes collègues que
je m'adresse qu'à vous monsieur Gard des
saau en fait si jamais le Sénat se
mettait en tête de ralentir le garde a
dit que on y consacrera le temps qu'il
faudra mais d'adopter des amendements
qui fragiliserait la possibilité
d'adoption à l'Assemblée nationale je
voudrais prévenir d'embler les collègues
dans ce cas-là nous reviendrons à la
procédure d'initiative parlementaire une
proposition de loi a été adoptée au
Sénat il suffit que l'Assemblée
nationale la vote en l'état en l'état et
nous irons au référend
et pour ce ah bah si ma ma ma
compréhension de la Constitution est que
dès lors qu'une proposition de loi a été
adopté dans les mêmes termes par les
deux assemblées la suite et le
référendum c'est la Constitution le le
le président de la République ou le
gouvernement peuvent choisir entre le
référendum ou le Congrès lorsqu'il
s'agit d'un projet de loi
constitutionnel donc d'initiative
gouvernementale s'il s'agit d'une
initiative parlementaire c'est
systématiquement le référendum et je ne
vois pas comment le président de la
République pourrait décider de ne pas
recourir au référendum après que la que
nous ayons satisfait à la double
exigence d'un vote conforme dans les
deux assemblées et en ce qui nous
concerne parlementairire militant
féministe défenseuse du libre choix nous
n'avons pas peur du référendum donc ce
n'est pas notre premier choix mais si
nous devions arriver là nous irons voilà
ces choses sont claires et j'espère que
ça va infusé dans les réflexions de nos
collègues du Sénat et enfin dernière
chose c'est juste un petit rappel
historique l'ARIPA a été créée en 2016
al c'est pas que je sois sourcilleuse et
cetera mais de temps en temps de temps
en temps ce rappeler qu'elle a été
considérablement améliorée depuis 2007
que elle a été le travail engagé a été
poursuivi l'ARIPA et a
été fourni de nouveaux collaborateurs
des nouvelles lois sont venu mais elle a
été créée en
2016 euh ben on on fait toute les
questions et vous répondez ensuite donc
Joceline Antoine et qui sera suivi par
olivierre
Richard merci madame la présidente
monsieur le garde disou je vais être
très bref puisque vous avez répondu en
grande partie à ce que je voulais ce
dont je voulais vous entretenir sur
l'actualité actuelle de la directive
européenne sur les violences fait aux
femmes dont l'article 5 prévoit
d'instaurer donc la une définition
pénale unique de viol fondé sur la sur
la notion de
consentement l'opposition de la France
me semble quand même un petit peu
problématique parce qu'elle rentre en
contradiction avec la convention
d'Istanbul du Conseil de l'Europe que la
France a signé en 2014 et qui impose aux
États-membres de criminaliser les actes
sexuels non consentis alors bien sûr ne
s'agit que d'une
convention
euh j'ai bien entendu votre exposé sur
l'aspect de la démission juridique du
viol mais bon afin de protéger au mieux
les victimes ne conviendrait-il pas de
garder les notions de menac violence
contrainte et surprise tel que le
prévoit notre droit et qui
effectivement est un des plus
contraignants
d'Europe mais également de considérer en
plus que l'absence de consentement est
légalement constitutive d'un viol parce
que dans l'état d'esprit des victimes
c'est quand même pas tout à fait la même
chose et je pense que ça encouragerait
aussi les femmes à porter PL plus
facilement dans la démarche
psychologique voilà je vous remercie
Olivia Richard merci présidente monsieur
le garde des saau sénatrice des Français
établieur de France je suis très
sensible au rayonnement de la France sur
la scène
internationale et dès lors l'inscription
de l'IVG dans la Constitution me paraît
me paraîtrait être un symbole très fort
euh et une réaffirmation d'un
attachement à des valeurs humanistes
indispensable donc je voterai bien
entendu ce texte en espérant qu'il qu'il
arrive vite et qu'il ne fasse pas
l'objet d'une procédure plus compliquée
même si en effet elle serait possible
euh donc les Françaises établi hors de
France pardon de de parler d'elle parce
que c'est une population qui est
lointaine mais connue mais comment
accéder à l'IVG dans des pays où c'est
totalement interdit ça implique de
rentrer en France pourquoi le Sénat
avait adopté un amendement à l'occasion
de la discussion budgétaire qui a
disparu à la faveur d'un 493 qui
prévoyait la possibilité de rapatrier
les femmes qui devaient rentrer en
France pour bénéficier de cela vous le
savez il y a des délais contraints je
regrette la disparition de cette
disposition euh deuxième chose nous
avons entendu le le Premier ministre
parler de la possibilité de porter
plainte en ligne euh là encore des ce
serait très précieux pour les femmes
françaises à l'étranger qui ne peuvent
pas aller porter plaintte au consulat
et ça pose néanmoins le problème nous
avons des conventions internationales
qui interdisent de déplacer les enfants
de façon euh j'allais dire unilatérale
donc un mari violent car généralement ce
sont les maris qui sont violents euh a
des droits sur ses enfants de façon euh
en tout cas en fonction de la droit la
loi local mais même du droit français et
donc une femme qui tente de rentrer en
France pour échapper à son bourreau
emmène ses enfants et se retrouve euh
elle-même coupable d'un d'un déplacement
illicite d'enfants euh les agents du
ministère des Affaires étrangères plus
particulier le Bureau d'aide aux
familles euh en lien avec votre
ministère euh tente d'expliquer aux
autorités françaises locales lors du
retour que non ce ne sont pas des
enlèvements non c'est une mise à l'abri
et néanmoins il faut une évolution
législative pour sécuriser et
permettre le retour en France de ces
femmes qui parfois non même pas de
famille hein se retrouent totalement
isolé les Français l'étrangers sont loin
d'être tous des expatriés
euh lorsqu'ell le sont c'est-à-dire on a
encore beaucoup de femmes qui suivent
leur mari à l'étr manger elles dépendent
pour la légalité de leur situation la
régularité de leur situation du visa du
conjoint qui trouve encore un moyen de
pression supplémentaire puisque retirer
le passeport ne suffit plus pour
fragiliser leur situation et il m'a été
rapporter des cas dans certains pays où
en cas de séparation bien sûr la femme
perd son visa et doit repartir mais où
les enfants sont invités à rester bon
d'autres cas encore où le mari quitte la
femme F quitte le pays dénonce le visa
de son épouse et donc de ses enfants qui
se retrouvent irrégulier et doivent
payer une asreinte journ bref il y a des
situations inextricables et tout est
encore pire à l'étranger voilà merci
pour votre
attention je vous laisse la parole pour
répondre à ces nombreuses questions
monsieur le
ministre il est déjà voilà merci Madame
la président madame la sénatrice billon
euh d'abord merci pour vos gentils mots
à propos de
notre collaboration efficace et
effective le
texte que vous avez que vous nous avez
présenté et qui a permis me semble-t-il
de faire beaucoup évoluer les choses
nous avons dit
clairement
que un homme ne peut plus dire qu'une
gamine de 14 ans était consentant
exception faite de notre petit
amendement Roméo Roméo et Juliette
euh qui a été disons-le
débattu euh la notion de danger sur sur
l'ordonnanche de de protection est une
exigence
constitutionnelle alors il faut qu'on
trouve n pas si simple que cela mais je
pense que nous avons trouvé un un
équilibre euh un équilibre entre les
atteintes aux libertés fondamentales
parce que ça va très vite et queil y a
se poser la question du contradictoire
parce que bon
euh on prend quelqu'un par la peau du
dos on le on le vire du domicile
conjugal euh il faut qu'il y ait aussi
euh matière à ce que le contradictoire
puisse à un moment s'exercer qu'il
puisse faire valoir ses droits donc il y
avait l'équilibre indispensable entre
une une une une atteinte aux libertés
fondamentales sans déclaration de
culpabilité je le rappelle parce que on
est dans de l'extrême urgence donc le
procureur intervient Phe de
contradictoire ensuite et la Cour de
cassation a dit je vous transmettrai la
décision que la constitutionnalité euh
était au fond subordonnée à l'existence
d'un danger alors ensuite vient la
définition de ce qui est un danger
j'entends tout ce que vous dites mais
euh ce cette proposition de loi doit
doit être examinée dans les dans les
heures qui viennent devait dans les
jours qui viennent un mois de mars ça a
été reporté mais il n'était pas exclu
qu'elle soit débattue dès hier et puis
pour cause d'embouteillage si si si
j'ose dire ça a été reporté au mois de
mars mais ce n'est pas à vous que je
vais dire qu'il y aura aussi un travail
parlementaire et qu' aura aussi mais
comme
d'habitude pour objet d'enrichir le
texte
bon
potentiellement donc tout ça va être
discuté la recherche pour moi c'est
celle d'un équilibre sans perdre de
l'efficacité je dois dire que jusqu'à
maintenant on a de façon drastique
réduit les délais
et il est indispensable oui qu'on puisse
intervenir en cas de de de danger
d'urgence
avec les difficultés de définir des
concepts comme cela mais moi je ne doute
pas une seule seconde que nous allons y
parvenir et que cette
ordonnance ultra rapide est au fond
d'une une grande nécessité et et et nous
le savons bon sur la médecine Sénégal
c'est c'est j'ai eu des échanges déjà
avec la ma collègue chargée de la Santé
bon on est là sur de de
l'interministériel effectivement on a
beaucoup de choses à renforcer je je je
il y a ce sujet que vous évoquez il y a
le sujet de la psychiatrie également est
un sujet majeur très imbriqué
avec la détention par exemple mais aussi
la
prévention donc là-dessus euh on est en
train de de de travailler on a à
l'esprit l'un et l'autre que il est
indispensable que nous
renforcions tout ce qui permet
euh aux femmes victimes d'avoir accès à
la médecine
égale vous m'avez interrogé encore sur
la la féminisation de la magistrature
bien alors si si j'étais cynique ce que
je ne suis pas je vous dirais laissons
faire les choses euh quand je vais aux
prestations de serment
des auditeurs de justice je suis
toujours surpris quand il y a un garçon
qui vient faire le petit selfie il y en
a plus c'est pratiquement exclusivement
féminin hein le barreau s'oriente aussi
vers cela bon et moi en ce qui me
concerne j'ai proposé au Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature euh des
procureurs procureurs généraux qui sont
des femmes bon et je dois vous dire je
sais pas si c'est rassurant mais c'est
une réalité mon cabinet est
composé très majoritairement de femmes
FEM magistrat et enfin pour être un peu
plus sérieux répondre à vos
préoccupations dans le PJ que vous avez
voté on a pris un certain nombre de
dispositions pour que non seulement les
femmes qui sont magistrate soit
magistrate évidemment mais qu'elle
puisse accéder évidemment à au
postes hiérarchique qui leur sont d
voilà ce que je peux vous répondre
madame madame Rossignol madame Rossignol
oui harip pas rendons rendons à César
mais oui mais voilà non mais d'ailleurs
non mais je je n'en ai pas fait une
appropriation
euh mensongère concéderzle moi j'ai
évoqué haripa je oui il me plaît de vous
dire à cet instant que je sais qu' à
l'origine d'aripa
euh vous posez des moi vous savez je
suis je demande qu'à être convaincu
donc la question des des des des
cours
spécialisé vous avez évoqué euh le
terror le terrorisme vous avez évoqué le
stupéfiant bande
organisé je suis saisi d'une question en
ce moment on ne rien vous cacher parce
que on me dit mais quand on trafique des
stupes en bande organisé c'est la cour
d'assise spécial mais quand deux
trafiquants de stup
s'entretuent c'est le la cour d'assise
traditionnel est-ce qu'il y a pas là
Monsieur le Ministre une difficulté on
réfléchit là-dessus et de la même façon
on peut réfléchir à ce que vous dites
pas maintenant je ouais ouais mais
j'entends bien mais là aussi l'équilibre
est toujours difficile à trouver parce
que on m'a déjà beaucoup reproché euh
n'était pas à l'initiative de ça mais
j'ai j'ai j'ai ensuite évidemment était
totalement engagé sur les cours
criminelles départementales pour les
raisons que j'ai évoqué m'a beaucoup
reproché de vouloir tuer la cour
d'assise traditionnel à cela je
répondais que j'avais renforcé la
souveraineté populaire euh puisque
j'avais exigé que dans le cadre de la
définition d'une culpabilité il il y ait
une majorité de juristes qui n'était
plus le cas
bon alors il faut aussi qu'on garde
cette cour d'assise parce que il est
important dans une grande démocratie que
au fond le peuple au nom de qui on rend
la justice puisse y participer mais mais
ce que vous dites mérite
expertise ou j'entends j'entends euh
c'est vrai que traite des êtres humains
en bande organisé
bon l'idée de de ces juridictions
spécialisées c'est pour protéger les
jurés d'ailleurs hein bon on a eu un
certain nombre d'affaires où les
magistrats
professionnels on a considéré qu'ils
étaient mieux à même de faire face à une
criminalité du du haut du spectre comme
on dit en langage technocratique c'estàd
que on avait eu vent de ce que des jurés
pouvaient être menacés d'ailleurs on
avait parfois la difficulté qui était de
les
réunir euh voilà et on a vu des
défections d'ailleurs donc je suis
opposé à rien a priori on va on va
réfléchir on peut même réfléchir
ensemble vous savez je le redis madame
Rossin je vous l'ai déjà dit que la
porte de la Chancellerie est est
ouverte bah oui je sais non mais vous
vous dites AR pas et moi je dis la porte
est ouverte euh chacun dit son petit
truc aussi parce que c'est vrai bon
voilà hein
euh sur la question question madame la
sénatrice Antoine
de de
l'Europe
bon d'ailleurs c'est une question qui
est aussi posée par Madame Rossignol
qu'il faudrait pas ajouter dans le texte
que le viol est une relation non
consentie je je alors d'emblé mais sans
y avoir réfléchi davantage je pense que
la définition du viol telle que nous
l'avons dans notre code pénal
nécessairement mais implicitement
rappelle le défaut de consentement
puisque on parle de violence on parle de
de de surprise par exemple de contrainte
bon bien sûr donc ce sont des choses qui
sont me semble-t-il claires je suis pas
insensible à
l'idée d'être peut-être plus pédagogue
auprès des victimes ça se réfléchit moi
je ne suis contre rien mais ce que je
veux réaffirmer ici parce que j'ai vu
toute une polémique
monter que le garde des saau entre autre
gouvernement auquel il
appartient serait rétrograde frileux sur
ces questions
bon c'est pas un
argument dont on peut faire son beur
électoraliste ma préoccupation je l'ai
dit c'est la vôre aussi je suis vraiment
très heureux de de de d'avoir entendu ce
que vous aviez à dire sur cette question
c'est faisons attention quit tropérain
parf fois malembrasse et au fond vouloir
protéger le dire et puis se voir au
final opposer une décision qui serait
une décision qui s'imposerait à tous de
la Cour de justice je l'aurais dit c'est
une question de compétence et j'ai j'ai
j'ai trouvé un peu pas utiliser les
grands mots les mots qui fchent mais un
peu malhonnête la présentation qui a
parfois été faite des
choses au fond j'entendais nous nous
avons les solutions nous nous protégeons
les femmes nous et nous et nous et le
gouvernement est en retrait non pas du
tout le gouvernement il dit faisons très
attention à ce que ce que nous essayons
de de construire au quotidien a y a
encore des failles aant encore beaucoup
de boulot et c'est un combat qui
malheureusement n'est jamais terminé
n'aboutissent pas à pire que ce que nous
avons aujourd'hui dans le cadre d'une
législation qui sait ce que c'est que le
viol qu' le reprime et qu' le réprime de
façon plus sévère que les autres pays
européens alors faire de la petite
polache là-dessus ça m'a un peu ch
Griner euh parce que je je le redis
d'ailleurs vous savez si vous êtes au
fait du sujet euh qui a de vraies
discussions de juristes de très très
haut niveau la question c'est celle de
la compétence et en déplais à certains
euh bah cette question là elle mérite
quand même d'être examinée on peut pas
faire n'importe quoi moi je n'ai pas
envie évidemment que on fasse n'importe
quoi et qu'au fond le résultat obtenus
soit pire que ce que nous avons madame
Richard la la la la plainte en ligne
pour l'étranger n'est pas prévu
maintenant mais il faut qu'on y
travaille
alors les sujets que vous évoquez sont
pour moi pour le ministère un casse-tête
s'agisse des questions
d'adoption alors vous me dites changer
la législation alors la difficulté c'est
que notre législation n'a pas vocation
s'appliquer dans des pays souverains et
donc il y a la voie évidemment de
l'évolution législative pour faciliter
le parcours de femmes qui V veulent
revenir en France tout ça on peut
l'envisager et moi si vous avez des
propositions à me faire je suis tout à
fait preneur en revanche on est
davantage sur du du du du traité fautil
bilatéral multilatéral pour essayer
d'obtenir aussi de nos partenaires une
forme de réciprocité par exemple et de
permettre que une femme qui revient avec
ses enfants parfois d'ailleurs dans le
cadre d'une décision de justice rendue
en France par un un juge français ne
fasse pas l'objet de tracasserie
tracasserie c'est doucement euphémique
hein vous vous vous l'avez dit j'étais
confronté à une question de de
d'adoption c'est un véritable casse-tête
parce que on ne peut pas opposer si
j'ose dire même si on essaie de le faire
dans la dans la discussion dans la
tractation on peut pas
opposer notre législation à d'autres
pays mais ça m'intéresse beaucoup que
vous veniez me faire part des choses qui
à votre sens pourraitêtre évoluer pour
permettre à nos compatriotes qui sont à
l'étranger euh d'être LTI si j'ose dire
à meilleur enseigne
euh à qui dois-je encore répondre et
bien
c'estésid c'est à moi qu' revient de
conclure et en fait ce sera pas quelques
questions mais plutôt quelques remarques
à la suite de cette audition que je
m'étais noté au fur et à mesure de votre
intervention vous avez évoqué la justice
patrimoniale il se trouve que c'est une
proposition
que probablement notre groupe devrait
porter le groupe Union centriste en tout
cas il fait partie des choix qui nous
ont été proposés et le vote est en cours
et j'espère en tout cas personnellement
j'y suis très favorable et j'ai voté
pour ce texte et je crois que nous avons
de bonnes chances qu'il puisse être
inscrit dans une niche prochaine de
l'Union centriste sur les pô viv j'avais
quelque chose à à préciser finalement
pour être allé en Espagne et comme vous
le dites c'est toujours l'exemple
finalement quand je vois les pôles
puisque aujourd'hui je suis invité dans
un certain nombre de juridiction pour
voir ces pôles se mettre en place ou
rencontrer les présidents de tribunaux
ou les procureurs généraux nous allons
plus loin finalement que ce que fait
l'Espagne puisque en Espagne même si
c'est dans un même bâtiment le pénal et
le civil ne se parlent pas alors que là
le pénal et le civil vont se parler pour
aller effectivement dans le sens que
nous souhaitions c'est que ce soit une
une affaire globale
qui soit traité dans toutes ces
dimensions femmes hommes enfant et
effectivement nous sommes nous nous
allons plus loin et et je suis très
heureuse de faire ce ce Tour de France
en ce moment un petit élément qui m'a
été signalé vous savez qu'il y a
toujours des gens qui nous suivent à
l'extérieur sur le fait qu'il y a eu un
petit un sondage qui a été fait sur le
contrôle coeritif et de savoir s'il
devrait faire partie de notre arsenal
pénal en tout cas il semblerait 96 % des
personnes soient prononcé pour je pense
que de toute façon c'est effectivement
un sujet à travailler puisque l'avantage
du contrôle coercitif et je sais que nos
gendarmes de liomne par exemple s'y
forment c'est ce sont des éléments de
preuve pour bien montrer qu'il n'y a pas
d'égalité il n'y a pas de parole contre
parole mais bien un auteur qui a mis en
place tout un système pour pouvoir
mettre sa victime sous emprise et on
fait porter c'est un peu pour ça que
j'étais heureuse de vous entendre sur le
viol euh on fait porter sur l'auteur la
responsabilité de ces actes et non pas
sur la victime à savoir si elle était
sous-empris si machin si truc
euh sur et d'ailleurs puisque nous
parlons de formation à ces sujets-là je
pense que ces formations aideront aussi
beaucoup à mieux poursuivre les viols et
à probablement avoir un petit peu moins
de classement sans suite dont on on dit
souvent qu'effectivement c'est manque de
preuve mais mais parfois euh en tout cas
j'ai un un cas bien précis en tête où
globalement on est à peu près assuré
quand même que le monsieur s'est très
mal comporté et probablement pas qu'avec
la personne qui a osé aller porter
plainte le classement sans suite est
très gênant parce que bah globalement si
on poursuit pas on sait qu'il va
continuer et donc c'est vrai que ce
manque de preuve ou de de le le fait de
pas creuser et je pense que en étant
mieux formé on trouve plus d'éléments
également sur le comportement des
auteurs sur la remarque de notre
collègue Laurence Rossignol
effectivement que je comprends
parfaitement parce que le procès entre
autres French bkqueé et en tout cas tout
ce qui est porno ça mérite d'être
franchement publque qu'il ait une grosse
publicité autour pour montrer que non on
ne fait pas n'importe quoi et que oui le
porno c'est de la violence en tout cas
dans dans ces sujetsl euh donc voilà et
pour conclure sur l'ARIPA alors moi
j'avais déjà fait la même réflexion sur
sur les maisons France servic dont je
voyais que parfois certains se
gargarisaient et en oubliant qu'il y
avait les maisons de service au public
qui étaient ouvertes quand même depuis
quelques années
euh mais je voulais et voilà donc des
choses qui se qui se développent euh
donc effectivement rendons à César je
sur l'ARIPA vous avez mentionné
effectivement des montants nous y
reviendrons quand nous remettrons notre
rapport sur les familles
monoparentales puisque on se rend compte
qu'en fait aujourd'hui il traite
beaucoup le flux des nouveaux entrants
et assez peu le stock euh ancien et donc
nous ne savons pas aujourd'hui vraiment
mesurer le nombre de euh de pensions
alimentaires qui n'étaient pas payé et
qui aujourd'hui pourrait être recouvré
par rapport au stock donc voilà nous
demanderons très probablement d'avoir
une petite analyse sur le sujet vous
voyez ce n'était pas vraiment des
questions mais des complément
d'information ou de sur nos des
compléments d'information également sur
nos travaux donc il me reste vraiment à
vous remercier euh du temps que vous
nous avez consacré de l'exhaustivité des
sujets que vous avez pu évoquer et puis
B puisque vous avez ouvert votre porte à
de nombreux membres de la délégation